Arthroscopic ankle fusion is a minimally invasive
surgical procedure that fuses, or joins, the
ankle bones together.
The ankle is the joint that connects the leg
and the foot.
The ankle joint includes the two lower leg
bones, called the tibia and the fibula, and
the ankle bone, called the talus.
Together the ends of the tibia and the fibula
create a mortis, or a slot, for the talus
which forms the bottom of the ankle joint.
Tissues called ligaments and tendons support
the ankle bones.
Ligaments attach bones to bones and tendons
attach muscles to bones.
The ankle joint allows the foot to move up
and down.
Articular cartilage on the ends of bones is
a smooth gliding covering that allows fluid
joint movement.
Ankle fusion, also known as arthrodesis, is
a surgical procedure that joins the ankle
bones together so they no longer move or rub
against each other.
Doctors may recommend this procedure for conditions
that lead to severe ankle joint damage and
pain.
The most common condition is osteoarthritis,
also known as degenerative joint disease.
In the late stage of osteoarthritis, cartilage
covering the ends of the bone is worn away,
exposing bare bone.
This, along with the growth of bony projections
called bone spurs, causes swelling, pain,
and limited movement of the joints.
Another condition that may require ankle fusion
is rheumatoid arthritis, where the patient’s
own immune system attacks the joints.
Any condition that destroys the joint surface,
such as a severe bone infection or death of
bone tissue, called osteonecrosis, may also
require fusion of the ankle joint.
To begin the procedure, the surgeon will hold
the foot down with straps to be able to see
inside the joint space better.
Next, two tiny keyhole incisions will be made
on the ankle.
A small tube, called a cannula, with a camera
inside it will be inserted through one incision.
Surgical instruments will be inserted through
the other incision.
The surgeon will use the surgical instruments
to remove cartilage and damaged bone from
the bottom surface of the tibia.
This will also be done to the top surface
of the talus.
After this, the surgeon will remove the arthroscopic
tools and foot straps.
Then two or three metal guide pins will be
placed through the bones of the ankle joint.
The surgeon will use the guide pins to place
hollow screws which hold the bones in place.
Finally, the incisions will be closed with
sutures.
After ankle fusion, the patient will no longer
be able to move the ankle joint.
However, fusion removes the pain caused by
arthritic surfaces rubbing together and other
joints in the foot continue to allow limited
movement.